You know in the first
Jurassic Park movie,
there was that scene with the
glass of water in the car's cupholder,
with ripples on it to show just how heavy
the approaching T-Rex's footsteps were?
Well, this thing behind me is technically
called the "Large Mobile Shaker",
but the folks here at the
University of Texas?
They call it
the "T-Rex",
because it's a machine designed
to shake the ground itself.
- We have five shakers.
They go from a small one,
that's right behind me.
And we call that an "urban shaker"
because you can bring it downtown
and not get into trouble with shaking.
And then we have very, very large ones,
Liquidator and T-Rex.
Liquidator is a low frequency vertical
shaker where we generate surface waves.
Like surface waves from earthquakes,
but ours are linear, typically,
and earthquakes can be non-linear.
[loud vibration with descending tone]
T Rex is a tri-axial shaker.
Tri-axial means that the shaker,
only one at a time,
it can shake vertically,
it can shake horizontally,
and it can go transverse.
It can go up to about 60,000 pounds force
vertically, and about half horizontally.
We have been all over the United States.
We have sensors that we've designed
and we will push in
because there are pushing rams
on the back of Liquidator and T-Rex,
so that we can install sensors
and then watch the wave go down.
Many times we're watching the wave
propagate away from us, but other times
it's very helpful
to watch the wave going down,
and seeing how poorly
the soil might behave due
to large amplitude shaking,
which is what you don't want.
We just came back from Wyoming,
where they're going to
build new power plants,
and the earthquake design is critical.
And we generated a 6000-foot-long wave.
Now we generated a two foot long wave,
too, but going through the range.
So that means we could evaluate
the stiffness profile down to half a mile.
With no boreholes!
That is really a true accomplishment
and a very, very cost effective addition
to the design of the plant.
So this is a sensor.
It's a big magnet with a coil.
The coil is going
through the magnetic field.
We were out there in Wyoming
and the darn cows walked by.
Fortunately, they didn't break any cables,
but we had to stop testing
because they made more noise.
They were right out there
and we were half a mile away.
Oh, my goodness.
Every time we go someplace,
we'll make sure the level won't damage structures.
Once we were on the UCLA campus,
and maybe didn't watch
what we were doing so much, and people
came running out of the building.
And that got us in trouble!